NIGHT AT 7.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
A HELPFUL HINT ABOUT HOW YOUR
GOVERNMENT WORKS.
IF YOU EVER SEE CONSENSUS
FORMING IN WASHINGTON RUN.
SOMETHING AWFUL IS ABOUT TO
HAPPEN.
IT WAS A TOTAL CONSENSUS THAT
OUR TRADE DEALS COULD NOT BE
BETTER AND HELPED EVERYONE.
AMERICA'S MANUFACTURING SECTOR
DIED AND HUGE PARTS OF THE
MIDDLE-CLASS DIED.
AND THEN BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS ON
THE IRAQ WAR AND WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION THAT WE WOULD FIND
THERE AND DIDN'T.
AND THERE WAS CONSENSUS ON THE
BANKING REGULATION BEFORE THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS HIT.
AND CONSENSUS ON AN ALL-SEEING
STATE THAT IS NOW SCANNING YOUR
FACE AND READING YOUR TEXT.
THERE WAS MUCH DEBUT ABOUT THOSE
POLICIES.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
A NEW CONSENSUS IS FORMING ABOUT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT MAY LOOK BAD, BUT CALM DOWN,
IT'S FINE.
EVERYTHING IS JUST FINE!
THAT'S THE NEW WORD FROM MAX
BOOT A COLUMNIST FOR JEFF BESOS.
HERE'S THE LATEST.
THIS IS FROM BOOT'S APPEARANCE
ON CNN LAST NIGHT.
>> I AM READY TO DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
IT'S NOT ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT'S IN WASHINGTON, D.C., BUT
THE PRESIDENT WHO IS LAWLESS AND
OUT OF CONTROL.
>> Tucker: WHO IS THIS GUY?
MAX BOOT CALLS HIMSELF A FOREIGN
POLICY EXPERT.
THAT TITLE DIDN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
IT ALLOWS BOOT TO AGITATE FOR
MORE COUNTER-PRODUCTIVE FOREIGN
LAWS.
HE DEMANDED MILITARY
INTERVENTION IN AFGHANISTAN,
IRAQ, SYRIA, LIBYA, IRAN AND
NORTH AND CALLED FOR THE U.S. TO
TOPPLE THE SAUDI MONARCHY.
BOOT FELL INTO THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION NUTTINESS FOR 2 YEARS.
IT'S HARD TO THINK OF ANYONE IN
THIS COUNTRY MORE DISCREDITED
FROM MAX BOOT.
GOING TO HIM FOR FOREIGN POLICY
ADVICE IS LIKE GIVING JEFFREY
DAMER A COOKING SHOW.
THE KEY IS NEVER APOLOGIZE.
NEVER ADMIT FAULTS NO MATTER
WHAT.
WATCH MAX BOOT EXPLAIN THE IDEA
OF TOPPLING THE LIBYAN
GOVERNMENT WAS BRILLIANT.
WE JUST DIDN'T DO IT RIGHT.
>> WE DID A GREAT JOB OF
OVERTHROWING GADDAFI BUT NOTHING
TO SECURE THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS A SIMILAR LACK OF
PLANNING FOR OUR PULL OUT IN
IRAQ.
THERE WAS LITTLE SENSE OF WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN WHEN U.S. TROOPS
LEFT IN 2010.
WE CAN'T BE QUICK IN AND OUT.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
>> Tucker: BOOT DOESN'T EXPLAIN
HOW IT WORKS.
HE DOESN'T NEED TO EXPLAIN.
EVERYONE KNOWS HIS ASSUMPTION IS
THE SAME AS WASHINGTON'S
ASSUMPTION.
MILITARY OCCUPATION IS ALWAYS
THE RIGHT ANSWER.
SENDING SOMEBODY ELSE'S KIDS TO
A FOREIGN COUNTRY IS ALWAYS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP PLEDGED TO
PULL AMERICANS OUT OF SYRIA BOOT
WENT CRAZY ON PRINCIPLE.
NO TROOPS CAN EVER LEAVE.
>> THERE IS NOBODY WHO KNOWS
ANYTHING ABOUT THE SITUATION IN
SYRIA WHO RECOMMENDS DOING THIS.
THIS IS A CHRISTMAS GIFT TO
AMERICA'S ECONOMY.
THIS WILL HELP ISIS, RUSSIA AND
IRAN AND HURT ISRAEL AND OUR
KURDISH ALLIES.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID MAX BOOT NOT
SAY?
HE NEVER EXPLAINED HOW KEEPING
AMERICANS I
AMERICAN SI
AMERICAN S I
AMERICANS  I
AMERICANS IN SYRIA WOULD HELP
THE UNITED STATES.
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON CARES.
THAT'S WHY NO ONE ASKS QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR CURRENT MILITARY
COMMITMENTS?
ARE WE OVER-EXTENDED.
WE HAVE 175,000 ACTIVE DUTY
PERSONNEL SERVE OVERSEAS.
AMERICAN TROOPS ARE POSTED IN
158 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
THERE ARE ONLY 195 COUNTRIES ON
THE PLANET.
THIS MAP GIVES YOU THE SENSE OF
A SCALE OF IT.
THERE IS NO WORLD WAR IN
PROGRESS.
THIS IS PEACETIME.
THIS IS ONE PLACE AMERICAN
TROOPS ARE NOT.
THEY ARE NOT ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER PROTECTING US.
THEY SHOULD BE.
WE COULD USE THEM.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE DON'T KNOW THE NUMBER OR WHO
THEY ARE.
100,000 MORE ARE SHOWING UP
EVERY MONTH.
OVER TIME, THIS IS HOW COUNTRIES
COLLAPSE.
MAX BOOT DOESN'T THINK IT'S A
CRISIS.
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON DOES.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IS JUST A
RIGHT WING TALKING POINT FOR
TRUMP.
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT:
MEDICAL CARE IN MORACCO.
LUCKILY WE HAVE THE AFRICAN
LION.
U.S. MILITARY PERSONNEL
PARTICIPATED.
AND THE PLIGHT OF THE ETHIOPIA
NAVY.
OUR 6th NEAT IS ON.
THE NAVY BRAGGED ABOUT NEW TALKS
ABOUT BUILDING THE ETHIOPIA
NAVY.
DO YOU FEEL SAFER?
-- FLEET.
THEY TRANSPORTED 663 METRIC TONS
OF RELIEF SUPPLIES IN THE WAKE
OF A CYCLONE.
THAT WAS NICE.
IN HONDURAS WE HAVE 400 AMERICAN
TROOPS.
THE AIR BASE SQUADRON HELPED
EXTINGUISH AN AIR FIRE AND THEY
ARE BUILDING WATER TANKS IN AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THESE ARE ALL GOOD WORKS.
DONE AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE BY THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT WHAT ABOUT US?
WE ARE BEING INVADED.
NO OFFENSE TO THE ETHIOPIA NAVY,
BUT WE COULD USE AMERICAN TROOPS
CLOSER TO TIJUANA THAN AFRICA.
TROOPS PROTECTING OUR OWN